Hola bienvenidos una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de Franz 24 en español miles
de personas llegaron a España de manera
irregular en lo que va del año escapando
de sus países de origen y muchísimas de
ellas Lamentablemente Perdieron su vida
en el intento a través de dos rutas
mortíferas una loseva por el mar
Mediterráneo y otra la denominada ruta
canaria a través del Atlántico para
abordar este tema tan crítico nos
acompaña yema Santana él es periodista
hace años trabajando en migración fue
técnico de la comisión española de ayuda
al refugiado y también se desempeñó como
asesor del gobierno de las Islas
Canarias en materia de migraciones
actualmente es candidato Al senado en la
lista de Nueva Canarias llamada Santana
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de Franz 24
no Santiago para mí es un placer estar
contigo y con tu audiencia el placer es
nuestro Sin lugar a dudas para comenzar
Cuál es hoy en estos momentos la
situación en Canarias a nivel migración
no solo en términos de cifras no también
en cuanto a la acogida Cómo se
desarrolla hemos visto en los últimos
días imágenes desgarradoras con cientos
de personas siendo rescatadas mientras
decenas permanecen desaparecidas
Sí aquí tenemos bueno Esto es como
muchos mapas no uno sobrepuestos a otro
por ejemplo en el mar a esta hora ya es
de noche a esta hora pues hay cuatro o
cinco cayucos desaparecidos hay varias
neumáticas que están desaparecidas
a esta hora también hay familiares que
están mandando mensajes y preguntando
por si para saber si su hermano su madre
su padre a su hijo ha llegado a tierra o
no
en tierra hay una acogida que que se
despliega por parte del gobierno de
España y que tiene su fragilidad cuando
hay intensidad que tiene su fragilidad a
la hora de abordar esto por la
intensidad que necesita no porque aquí
no se trata de almacenar cajas de
zapatos en un almacén y todas caben de
determinada manera porque miden lo mismo
No aquí estamos viendo que llegan
hombres llegan mujeres llegan de
distintos países llegan niños solos
llega con sus madres llegan mujeres
embarazadas
bueno Y luego además de la acogida
tenemos que estar pendientes de que el
gobierno de España genere un traslado al
continente no porque hay siempre la
tentación de la Unión Europea y del
gobierno de España de intentar que estén
aquí el mayor tiempo posible
y para Canarias es fundamental que para
un lugar de recepción la acogida Sea
temporal y haya un posterior traslado a
donde las personas desean ir no han
sobrevivido para llegar hasta aquí no
para verse encerrados en una isla yo no
sé si toda la audiencia tiene constancia
de dónde queda Canarias no pero somos
unas Islas que están a la altura del
Sáhara occidental prácticamente muy al
sur de lo que viene siendo el estado
español de la Península ibérica y
y ha habido veces igual que las hay en
Grecia y en otras Islas la tentación de
utilizar las Islas como cárceles
Santiago no y
muy doloroso para todas las partes
hablemos de un tema que ha influido para
muchos en la ruta canaria no cree que
esta ruta se vio reactivada con Los
acuerdos europeos con terceros países
como por ejemplo Marruecos no que le
permitieron a estos controlar la
fronteras en el mar Mediterráneo Qué
efectos han tenido esos acuerdos y los
cambios en las relaciones entre España y
Marruecos hace ya más de un año sí Mira
bueno todas las personas saben Y ustedes
saben que que que las migraciones no hay
un factor determinante solo hay una un
combinado de factores no esta ruta vino
despuntando de 2019 con la pandemia pues
tuvo mucha incidencia y luego hubo pues
efectivamente un acuerdo entre España y
Marruecos mediante el cual Marruecos
pasaba a ser un control más efectivo
digamos por llamarlo de alguna manera
efectivo no porque al final este control
conlleva repeler a la gente alejarlas de
las costas de tener a hombres mujeres y
niños y meter los desiertos adentro para
que vuelvan a empezar digamos un poco
alejarlos del lugar en el que a Europa
le parecen preocupantes las personas que
intentan sobrevivir no
y hemos visto como en las últimas
semanas especialmente desde el 20 de
mayo en adelante ha habido un nuevo
repunte migratorio en el que se ha
combinado un poco el factor climático
por un lado pero por otro lado también
pues
me duele decirlo pero es así Nosotros
somos conscientes de que cuando hay
claves políticas que Marruecos pueda
utilizar para obtener beneficio propio
no va a dudar en utilizar a las personas
migrantes lo hemos visto en el pasado
ahora expira su acuerdo de pesca ahora y
elecciones generales en España Ahora hay
una serie de asuntos que Marruecos le
interesa Y puede ser que hay un factor
climático que que haya se haya dado buen
tiempo buena Mari y demás y las personas
hayan salido más Pero puede ser también
y es porque lo hemos visto No solo a
Marruecos Turquía y otros países
utilizan a las personas migrantes a las
más vulnerables a las más desfavorecidas
entre las desfavorecidas como arma
política como arma para conseguir
objetivos políticos no Y esto me parece
ya como Ciudadano del mundo no algo
absolutamente deleznable absolutamente
Ahora
hay personas empresas o determina dos
sectores que se benefician con la
existencia de migrantes irregulares que
no tienen derechos
Yo entiendo no yo entiendo que mira las
personas que tratan de migrar no siempre
vienen huyendo del hambre de la guerra
de una violencia
explícita no hay veces que simplemente
anhelan mejorar sus vidas anhelan
cambiar sus vidas anhelan encontrarse en
columna un antiguo amor anhelan ver a su
hermano que nunca lo han visto van
buscando a su padre que se fue hace 20
años es decir una serie de de factores
que que rodean las migraciones y la
mayoría de las personas transita por
avión
hay uno que no pueden transitar por
avión Y qué tiene que ver con que no se
les da facilidades para transitar por
avión no se les da un visado a partir de
ahí empieza todo un mercado un mercadeo
de de seres humanos que acaban en redes
de tráfico de personas y yo siempre digo
hay que acabar con las mafias Sí pero
propongo una medida que es económica
vías legales y seguras que la gente
pueda ir a una embajada solicitar un
visado y poder venir temporalmente un
tiempo poder regresar después pero a lo
que los estamos condenando al no expedir
visados al no admitir por esta forma de
viajar de forma regular es al mar y en
el mar han muerto siete mil personas en
los últimos cuatro años con la
necropolítica no gana nadie es posible
que se beneficien económicamente
determinado
[Música]
estructuras de la industria securitaria
pero a la larga no gana nadie porque
esta forma de migrar
genera dolor genera angustia y hay algo
Santiago y y culmino la reflexión y te
agradezco la pregunta hay algo que vengo
pensando en los últimos años y es que en
los últimos meses y es que de alguna
manera esta forma de migrar ha
perpetuado el sistema colonial es decir
al final estas personas que llegan que
sobreviven a la ruta son explotadas
posteriormente de la Unión Europea
porque no tienen sus derechos laborales
consolidados porque no tienen una
situación administrativa regular pero se
insertan en el mercado laboral y cobran
por debajo del salario mínimo
establecido sin ningún tipo de
aseguramiento por tanto al final el
sistema colonial que dicen que ya se
acabó se acabó quizás para las materias
primas Pero ha perpetuado con los
recursos humanos esta explotación o eso
al menos es lo que uno Lee cuando Mira
mucho a estas rutas migratorias muy
interesante este análisis
ahora vinculado esto que decías
previamente no las migraciones son un
flujo natural no todos estos flujos de
desplazamiento son cíclicos Vos mismo
decías dependen de varios factores de
hecho muchos de nosotros somos productos
de todos estos movimientos no de las
migraciones desde este enfoque Entonces
no representan una emergencia digamos
cree que si llega a una situación que
puede ser considerada digamos crítica o
de emergencia no es por los flujos de
movimientos en sí mismos sino por la
manera en que son gestionados
a Canarias en lo que va de año por
ejemplo han llegado 7.000 personas
en el continente europeo somos 440
millones o 450 millones estamos hablando
de una cantidad pequeña pero
probablemente si esto hubiese ocurrido
por vía aeropuerto en unas condiciones
de seguridad en las que las personas una
vez que llegan si no están bien puedan
volver si no tienen trabajo puedan
volver porque aquí ocurre que la gente
se endeuda para mí entonces una vez que
están aquí además no pueden regresar
porque no pueden no tienen documentos ni
siquiera para regresar no tienen dinero
para regresar y no tienen vergüenza para
volver y no pagar y además tienen miedo
creo que al final este abordaje que
hacen de las migraciones desde una
perspectiva securitaria
está generando una sensación de
emergencia
desorbitada desmedida esto gestionado de
otra forma tendría otra apariencia y
luego por otro lado alrededor de las
migraciones de los gobiernos siempre hay
una opacidad sobre Cuántas personas que
pasa porque están aquí hasta cuando
están aquí tiene que haber transparencia
para todos para ellos están migrando veo
algunas personas en las imágenes para la
ciudadanía local que es de acogida y
también
digamos transparentar Qué es lo que está
ocurriendo Quiénes son porque hay
personas que nunca han tenido contacto
tienen poco contacto consciente con la
globalización y de repente se ven Pues
en situaciones que le pueden generar
inseguridad no y y hay que atender estas
estas inquietudes y y creo que por los
estudios que hemos hecho en Canarias y
en otros lugares comparto con muchos
colegas todo este asunto la
transparencia y la opacidad genera miedo
y la ultraderecha en España en Colombia
en Perú en Argentina en cualquier lugar
aprovecha Estos espacios para
colonizarlos con el miedo para asustar
para generar pánico a una situación que
nada tiene que ver con eso sino que es
una situación de mera supervivencia
vinculado a esto que decía Chema nos va
quedando poco más de un minuto pero qué
escenarios prevé es un poco de acá
futuro teniendo en cuenta en lo que
decías no el ascenso de la derecha de la
Ultra derecha teniendo en cuenta los
resultados de las elecciones locales y
regionales de mayo
Mira sea cual sea el resultado yo creo
que hay una legión de compañeros y
compañeras que vamos a estar en frente
defendiendo los derechos nuestros y de
todas las personas porque creemos que
los derechos se defienden todos juntos
vamos a estar defendiendo los derechos
de todas las personas que están en
Canarias que estén en acogida y que
vivimos aquí eso por un lado pero no
solo creo que
el escenario es un escenario complejo
porque otoño suele ser una un momento
caliente de la ruta canaria porque hay
una situación climática en el sageli de
seguridad que es compleja porque senegal
tiene elecciones el próximo año y la
cosa está un poco caliente por tanto
hasta ahora han muerto siete mil
personas aproximadamente el 10% de las
personas que tratan de llegar en esta
ruta en esta ruta van a seguir moviendo
personas si no se activan vías legales y
seguras y se da cierta certidumbre Y eso
es lo más grave que pareciera que se
está planificando las muertes en lugar
de abordarlo
miran para otro lado y a mí me gustaría
pensar que lo harían con todas las
personas por igual pero si siete mil
personas blancas de la Unión Europea
hubiesen muerto en esta ruta en cuatro
años creo que las soluciones hubiesen
sido más tempranas en llegar Sí más
antena se nos pasó rapidísimo Se nos
acabó el momento Muchísimas gracias por
su participación y su presencia en la
entrevista de Franz 24
es un placer para mí estar aquí con
ustedes Santiago Muchísimas gracias por
abordar este tema gracias a usted una
vez más a nuestra audiencia como siempre
le invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
24.com